we're joined by dw correspondent maya
schweiter in washington and here in the
studio
william gluecropped our u.s election
here
expert good to have you both uh let's
start with you maya you are closest
to the white house what more can you
tell us
the information is very basic right now
terry it's basically what you've
lined out for us we know that he is
positive
we don't yet know if he's showing any
symptoms we know that
he and the first lady are quarantining
but we don't know
what sort of medical course it's going
to take now his doctors have said that
he's
feeling well that he's going to continue
to perform his duties to the best of his
ability but we are
in new territory right now in terms of
what's going to happen with the campaign
what's going to happen with his health
this is already been a year full of
unprecedented moments and here is yet
another one
the doctor donald trump's doctor has
tweeted
that or said that that trump would
continue to carry out his duties in the
white house
without disruption what are we to make
of that
well he's clearly trying to send a
positive message we've seen both the
president and the first lady tweeting
that
they're in good spirits and they'll get
through this together it will be
interesting to see
how this trickles out through the rest
of the power players
in washington as you noted hope hicks
the aid in question who has also tested
positive
was in close quarters with the leader of
the house of representatives recently
trump himself has been in rooms with the
leader of
the senate with the vice president these
are people who meet with each other
very often and this virus is extremely
contagious now of course we can't make
any predictions
but this is something that's going to
have to be kept an eye on at the very
least
and of course trump not well known for
wearing a mask in fact he often mocks
those
who do wear masks including his opponent
joe biden for wearing a mask so
cavalier attitude towards protection and
now this has come home to him
well i'll venture a prediction i think
there'll be a lot more
mask wearing and a whole lot of testing
going on william
this of course has massive political
ramifications depending
on the severity of the infection that
donald trump
has what impact could it have on the
election as maya said this is such an
unprecedented moment we are about four
weeks from the election
thousands if not tens of thousands of
ballots have already been mailed in
many of which for donald trump so
we're looking at a man who we don't know
what's going to happen he may bounce
back fine he may show no symptoms
like like many people have but he's
limited what he can do he's limited in
his campaigning he has to quarantine
maybe as maya pointed out members of his
staff
maybe members of the government both
democrats and republicans in all levels
senate house the white house might have
to quarantine
we just don't know and and we we saw
even joe biden who is much more uh
likely to be wearing a mask and his wife
and his aides
and they've been actually making a
political issue out of it murray mass
showing that they're wearing mass
showing they trust the science
uh that was something that donald trump
mocked him at the debate uh just a few
days ago
we and i think we can show a clip of of
just that moment
that really takes on new context now i
mean i have a mask right here i
put a mask on it you know when i think i
need it tonight as an example
everybody's had a test
and you've had social distancing and all
of the things that you have to but
i wear masks when needed when needed i
wear a mask
okay let me ask i don't have i don't
wear mess like him every time you see
him he's got a mask he could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
i will say i mean we have the word in
german that's also in english
schadenfreude and that is what
a lot of people are saying right now um
this is a man who has been denying the
science
that's been denying the protocols that
has had very lacks
uh restrictions in the white house
despite claims of of testing and this is
one of the major issues
this is where reality really meets the
trump world
which is they can't deny being sick just
like they haven't been able to deny this
pandemic and
what we need what amer the american
public needs what journalists need
what people all around the world need is
a white house that more or less sticks
to the truth is going to tell us what's
going on with the president
of the united states and many of his
closest advisers
it's more than just about donald trump
when the president has coronavirus
the presidency has coronavirus and that
has far-reaching
political and policy implications maya
we of course don't know how serious this
infection is for donald trump what is
going to happen with his health but
assuming the president is incapacitated
what's the protocol how will this be
dealt with
uh if trump becomes really sick
well all eyes then turn to vice
president mike pence who has
tweeted his uh thoughts and prayers for
the president
and the first lady and of course another
big question that comes up next is
well then what happens with the campaign
as you mentioned we are
barely four weeks out from a massive
presidential election a campaign that
has been
very tempestuous donald trump was
scheduled to go today to two rallies one
in wisconsin one in florida both
extremely hot states that both
candidates need to win
those are going to have to be canceled
now the president and the first lady are
going to have to quarantine
for 14 days we are 13 days out from the
second presidential debate there were
all sorts of jokes flying around
after the disaster that was the first
presidential debate that maybe the rest
should be cancelled
we don't know if we might actually be
looking at that at this point
okay we it must be said you know we all
wish donald trump a speedy uh
recovery or that his symptoms don't
become too serious in this situation but
if they were to become serious could the
election be postponed
there is some precedent for postponing
or rather for suspending
campaigns back in the early 20th century
another presidential candidate
was taken ill and his opponent suspended
his campaign for that duration but
postponing an election
would be a very extraordinary step as
william pointed out we have about
2 million ballots across the country
that have already been sent in
90 of us voters according to a bbc poll
have already
made up their minds who they're going to
vote for it would be a very messy
proposition
indeed to postpone an entire election
now of course as we said the campaign is
going to have to take on
an entirely new shape now a lot of eyes
are going to be on joe biden to see
how he responds to this latest news the
latest tweet that we
see from him is him attacking trump and
the trump administration
for their very lacks response to the
coveted pandemic we have
more than 200 000 people dead in this
country one million dead worldwide
and the president really has played to
his base that this is really not that
serious
that no one really has to worry about
this don't bother wearing a mask or
protecting himself
and now here we are william this is a
delicate situation also for the
democrats how they're going to respond
to this is there a risk
for the democrats in this if they try to
exploit the situation
with donald trump's health in question
how are they going to play this
it is a fine line i mentioned the word
shot in floyd just earlier and
the democrats have to be careful not to
seem to be gloating not to seem to be
making light of the fact that the
president may be sick and at the very
least
is tested positive for coronavirus what
they can do
is pivot back to the issue that they're
really trying to make this campaign
about which is healthcare which is
preserving what's left of obamacare it's
been chipped away a lot
but what's left of it trying to
strengthen it putting something new in
place if biden is elected to build on
that
um and by saying by making the case
donald trump
uh being the president is going to get
the best possible care you can get in
the country
which many americans particularly people
of lower economic means particularly
people of color
have not been able to get and have been
so strongly affected by this virus
that's the route that democrats will
probably take and they have to be
careful
not to gloat not to not to hit hard on
trump's uh playing down the virus before
and now having it
now maya there's great concern about uh
how far this in how far this infection
this hot spot has spread as it were
donald trump had contact of course
with joe biden at that campaign on
tuesday and a number of other people
as well is there a risk that joe biden
himself
could be infected
well i'm sure first thing in the morning
joe biden's going to wake up to this
news
and uh be taking at least one copied
test today we also know according to
white house insiders that
cnn is reporting that trump did a
closed-door big donor fundraiser
in new jersey after it was known that
his aid hope hicks
was positive so we're looking at what is
going to happen with joe biden we're
looking what's going to happen with
other
big donors with other washington
insiders you know
it really was stark when you watched the
debate
earlier this week to see how the
republicans
on the trump supporters on one side of
the room were mostly not wearing masks
and how the democrats and the biden
supporters on the other side of the room
really were it really is living in two
different realities in this country the
people who
don't believe that coronavirus is really
that big of a deal and the people who do
it will be interesting to see how this
spins out among trump supporters many of
whom
attend his rallies without sort of any
protection who don't mind standing cheek
and jowl with their fellow trump
supporters next to each other in these
big
aircraft hangars where he tends to have
his rallies
how are they going to react and how is
this going to bring this home to them
if at all does this mean that perhaps
the republicans
and the trump supporters can start
taking kovid seriously now you know
oh we're only at 200 000 people dead in
this country
let's see what happens maya thank you
very much for now that's our washington
correspondent maya schweiter and here in
the studio from our u.s
election coverage team william bluecroft
thanks terry
well first lady melania trump who has
also tested positive
has also tweeted she said that she and
the president are
feeling good and that she had postponed
all upcoming engagements
the white house has confirmed that the
president will not be making a planned
campaign trip to florida
on friday let's get a scientific
perspective
on all of this i'm joined now by eric
feigl ding he's an epidemiologist and a
senior fellow at the
federation of american scientists in
washington dc thank you for being with
us mr feigerling
what went through your mind when you
heard that president donald trump
had tested positive for the coronavirus
well it was actually just
it was a matter of time it was about
time because
he had been doing a lot of dangerous and
risky things
for example at the debate half the room
was masked
the democratic side half the room was
entirely unmasked
the republican side all his aides never
wore any masks
or did distancing whatsoever in any of
their travels
so and with hope hicks we actually now
with
this just in just a few minutes ago we
now know that
everyone tested negative on tuesday
everyone in the debate hall
but she tested negative on wednesday
morning but negative
positive on wednesday afternoon when she
got sick so this means
she because she sort of showed symptoms
then that
she was definitely carrying the virus
then and
potentially in the infectious
pre-symptomatic period
and donald trump testing so quickly
positive also means
he did not get it from her after she was
becoming infectious
he probably got it much earlier which
meant he may have also
been uh potentially asymptomatic
transmittable
at the at the debate so i think in
certain ways
it was inevitable given how risky they
were and potentially
that trump and hope hicks were both
transmitting the virus
at the debate despite testing negative
okay this is a shock
for americans and everyone else watching
this election of course
do you think the fact that donald trump
himself the president of the united
states has
contracted the virus will have an impact
on the way americans
approach this pandemic
i think so in certain ways i hope so
because half of america
has been in complete denial more like 40
completed now in terms of masks they
think it's overblown
they think it's just liberal media you
know
ramping this story up just to make trump
look bad but now trump himself has got
it so in certain ways the optics of
he wasn't careful he got it he actually
mocked biden
for wearing a mask at the debate and yet
here we are two days later i think that
will
turn some a lot of independents and
moderates to wake up to the reality that
this virus
is serious and if donald trump could get
infected
anybody can now you were one of the
first
to raise the alarm about the dangers of
this virus in the u.s do you think the
president being infected will impact
policy when it comes to dealing with a
pandemic moving forward
yeah there's a lot of health care reform
policies especially around
pre-existing conditions if anything the
supreme court
the u.s may shoot down obamacare
one week after the election in november
so there's a lot on the line
and i think in certain ways this points
out
if donald trump can have the best health
care in the world
by paying only 750 in taxes
every day americans should be as well
and should not be denied
coverage for a pre-existing condition
because 50 000 americans
more have a pre-existing conditions
every single day
uh and that's the number of people being
infected every day so i think in certain
ways this will steer the conversation
even of
health care even more and make trump
more vulnerable because this is health
care is his most
vulnerable issue mr feingolding thank
you very much for talking with us that
was epidemiologist eric feigley
so what about the financial fallout from
this news let's cross cross straight
over to our financial correspondent in
frankfurt ashutosh pandy tash this
is big news obviously what are global
stock markets making of it
well yes the sentiments have turned
negative and the reaction was swift
uh the japanese markets turned negative
uh they had
they were trading up by then and once
the news struck
uh they turn negative and even the
markets across europe have
opened in the red uh you can see the
decks behind me
struggling there at the bottom uh it's
the same in paris same in london so yes
at this point of time uh the markets are
really trying to process
how they should actually uh go ahead and
trade uh
they are trying to make sense of this
news and what impact would it have
on the markets going forward uh
basically there is an element of
uncertainty there
especially at a time when the us was
struggling to come up with a fresh
stimulus uh package and the white house
is playing a crucial role in those
negotiations there so
there is that element of uncertainty
there and and the traders are going for
safer assets like the dollar uh the yen
japanese then is performing better
uh so that's the that's the position as
of now but we should also keep in mind
that
uh when prime minister boris johnson
contracted the disease then also the
markets did turn negative
but they did settle down a little later
this time though it's a little different
because uh
it comes so close to the elections in
the u.s and that adds
to the uncertainty okay any indication
at this point
what will happen on wall street when
trading opens there
we don't expect anything different there
is going to be the same perhaps even
worse the uh
the futures markets are indicating that
the opens are
the markets are going to open in the
negative territory
so it's not going to be any different
there uh that there is going to be a lot
of volatility
with the elections inside and also
when as the markets try and make sense
of what kind of impact would it have on
the negotiations
uh related to that uh stimulus uh uh uh
in the us and and this news certainly is
going to overshadow any
other news that was slated for today and
was expected to have an impact on the
markets like the jobs
number for september ashitash thank you
very much for your insight sarah ashtosh
party in frankfort
uh let's get the view from brussels our
correspondent barbara basil is standing
by there where
a eu summit is underway it must be said
we'll get to that in just a moment but
first barbara
in a reaction from europe yet to the
news about president donald trump
testing positive for the coronavirus
european leaders are just beginning to
come back into the building and so far
the first
ones haven't mentioned it probably a
little bit later there will be an
official statement with the usual
best wishes for a speedy recovery
britain by the way
was the only country and the first one
to be early out of the starting blocks
wishing president trump all the best but
britain of course is not present
in the council building here behind me
anymore they
are out however if you look at the other
level what leaders might be
thinking and hearing this news this
morning
is of course it's striking fear into
their hearts
that the already chaotic election
campaign
in the united states might sort of
descend
into the next level that might the
elections might sort of completely
go down further towards
chaos and catastrophe
and so that is something that of course
european leaders don't want to see
everybody had hoped
that things might sort of drag
themselves over the line
but that doesn't seem to be sure now so
a lot of thought there
okay just uh thinking about
transatlantic relations
already in disarray to some degree could
this uh have
some impact on that
uh of course nobody will talk about this
at the moment you know if somebody falls
ill you sort of shut up and say okay
let's wait what will happen
and we will react later and we will
think about this
officially talk about this later however
it's clear transatlantic
relations had already been in complete
disarray
and it is really not to be seen as
everybody now thinks you know what can
be
salvaged from this complete chaos and on
the other hand of course european
leaders
have been looking at donald trump's
handling of the
kovit infections and the corona
epidemic with shocked because
it is so contrasting to what they do
look at this summit just here in
brussels
very carefully socially distant
everybody wearing masks very few aids
super hygienic conditions and we from
what we heard now from the
correspondents on the on the us side
trump going out and talking to people
nobody wearing masks and
trump for months and months denying that
this was a serious threat
so of course they now see this and think
we worked so hard to contain
the virus here in europe and look what
happened there
and i would not want to speculate what
might be going through
the minds of one or the other european
leaders at that point
let's get some european insight now
we're joined by francisca bronte
she's european affairs spokesperson for
the green party in germany's lower house
of parliament
the bundestag thanks for being with us
this morning what do you make
of president trump testing positive for
the coronavirus
it shows all the craziness of the
trump's
handling of the corona crisis over the
last couple of months and it shows again
that
with trump we don't have a reliable
ally in the fight the global fight
against covet 19.
and i think that we as europeans
really have to re-center our own efforts
and make sure that we become less
dependent on
external sources for our masks for our
sciences and really invest in our own
health
and then help other countries in this
world because the us won't be that actor
doing that any longer
which is a shame in the past certainly
the us would have played
a leading role now it's up for us
europeans
well of course there could be a change
of leadership in the us
until we hear otherwise we are still
assuming at this point that the u.s
election will go ahead
as planned how important is this
election
for europe it is of course
a very important moment when it comes to
the transatlantic relationship
but i believe that we as europeans
whoever wins
will have to focus on strengthening our
own strategic sovereignty
that we have to take over more
responsibilities and that means for
example for a german government
when we talk about european european
digital sovereignty
to invest in european technologies to
make sure that we
can have a safe digital infrastructure
and as the
germans are debating north stream too
this also comes back to
how sovereign do we want to be and i
think
the elections refocus us on debating
what we need to do to become more
able to define our own future as
europeans
mr now thank you very much that was
francisca brantner
european affairs spokesperson for
germany's green party in the buddhist
time
thank you
well let's bring in our brussels
correspondent barbara vasil who
is covering this story or at least
following reactions
while a u.s an eu summit is underway
there
uh barbara any reactions yet from europe
to the news about donald trump testing
positive for coronavirus
yes there have been some of course the
british government was first out of the
starting blocks very early this morning
wishing
donald trump a speedy recovery and now
the council president sean michelle
who officially presides over this eu
summit here
has also sent his good wishes and then
he added the sentence it's
is fight we are all continuing
to fight but what a different battle it
has been and this is something that will
be going through
everybody's minds here this morning all
the minds of the european leaders who
have assembled here again
because during the pandemic this summer
they really looked in shock and horror
at what was unfolding across the
atlantic
and we have just heard the green
parliamentarian talking about strategic
independence and sort of
the us not leading the battle against
corona worldwide anymore the european
union has really
felt this need to sort of take the lead
to talk to talk about
the international the worldwide
distribution of a vaccine as soon as it
comes on to the market to sort of
raise funds for this vaccine too so that
all countries also
developing countries would have access
to it and all these points they've
really felt pushed to sort of
go ahead but also i mean what a
different battle if you look at the
european summit unfolding here under
strictest hygiene measures all the
leaders wearing masks everybody
distancing very few aids in the room i
mean everything very restricted
journalists outside we can't even enter
anymore
so it is a very different picture but
the fear behind all this is of course if
you look at it
the fear behind all this is that the
okay
already chaotic and american election
campaign
might descend into total chaos might
might really sort of descend into
not not happen at all or be postponed or
something and
control over it might be completely lost
so that
really makes everybody afraid fears that
are not spoken but i'm sure that they're
being thought